malaria kills about 1.1 million people
every year most of them children in
sub-saharan Africa now an old method to
prevent the disease as making a comeback
children in Mali Senegal and other
African countries are swallowing malaria
pills throughout the rainy season when
malaria normally Peaks for decades
public health experts warned against
just this strategy known as chemo
prevention because it will cause
widespread drug resistance but the
alternative a massive number of deaths
every year seems worse I wanted to know
how African mothers scientists and
health workers felt about the
intervention so I traveled to Mali to
talk with them and to watch how the
pills are distributed to thousands of
kids during the rainy season on the day
before the rollout small groups of
health workers congregate for training
sessions they receive a backpack with
anti malaria pills and tools to dissolve
the pills and water here the medical
supervisor explains that these pills are
for healthy children they want to save
the gold-standard malaria medication for
when the children fall Center
on the day of the rollout mothers and
children arrive by foot and by donkey
cart from the farms where they work they
gather outside of a one-room schoolhouse
today a temporary clinic inside the
health workers mash up the pills plop
them in water and hand the bitter yellow
liquid to children to swallow it's
September and children in this village
have been taking the pills once every
month since the rainy season began in
July normally at this time children
suffering from malaria will fill
hospitals but with chemoprevention most
children remain healthy and their moms
don't need to worry throughout the day
community health workers repeat a mantra
better to prevent and to treat women
like malaria prevention for the kids
because they benefit so much from it
that's what he said because in addition
of saving money because they won't have
to take them to the hospital they also
have much time to take care of their
field the farm work and not of being
attending their sick child at home last
year the World Health Organization
recommended chemo prevention for
countries like Mali Senegal and Nigeria
places where malaria mainly strikes
during the rainy season
the intervention has been a decade in
the making because health officials were
concerned about side effects and about
the risk of resistance those fears are
actually justifiable but over the past
decade scientists have shown that the
treatment reduces malaria cases by more
than 80% the benefits outweigh the costs
as Buderus Issei who helped run the
largest trial in Senegal
I can't think that it will be
appropriate to not give this is God to
those who need them because of potential
diseases we have to use them and at the
same time we have to when you talk
continuously to keep tabs on resistance
researchers will analyze spots of blood
collected from malaria patients to see
if the parasites have evolved mutations
to overcome the therapy one of these
researchers Allison dico is thrilled to
see the intervention take off compared
to the current tool that we have for
malaria control it's it's really around
very high and when you have bed net and
when you have other interventions so we
believe that what TV does needed now is
to implement this very quickly science
behind Kim prevention is simple and in
studies it's clearly powerful now the
main obstacle is what some people in the
8th world called the last mile challenge
it's logistical hurdles it's why polio
has been so hard to eliminate even
though the vaccine has been around for
decades we optimistic that we can make
it but we need a strong commitment of
all medical authorities and maybe that's
what we there are 25 million children
who stand to gain from chemo prevention
if only health workers can reach them